- [Man] Amsterdam, Netherlands.
Famous for its stroopwafle
or stroopwafles,
its marijuana (coughing),
I mean baked goods.
And it's delicious, slippery
raw fish known as herring.
More importantly, Dutch new herring.
Yep, that's a headless raw fish. (ewing)
This one's gonna be delicious.
This is probably the most
famous dish in the Netherlands.
But to understand why we must
travel to the dish's origin.
Welcome to Scheveningen-
the seaside town obsessed
with the herring,
illustrated by this giant
herring eating statue.
I mean their town's flag even
has three herrings on it.
Oh wait, sorry, that's a
bad example; there we go.
Meet Cees. He's the
owner of Haring Huisje.
- [Man] And chomp.
So let's go back to Amsterdam.
(bell ringing)
Here they eat the herring
a little differently.
- [Man] But why the pickles and onions.
- [Man] The dish can't
be found in restaurants-
only these last surviving herring stores
scattered around the dam.
(screeching)
(dinging)
(relax grunting)
- [Man] OK, wish me luck.
(light ragtime music)
(light electronica)